appears to be hurting right now
[Applause]
apparently he got hit yeah he's hurting
but celtics are not and they get it done
very impressive win over a good
basketball team you say well you they
caught a good time on the schedule
celts don't make the schedule you play
the games they're assigned you
and boston did the job they had to do
tonight
we just wanted no part of that
basketball the turnover doesn't go to
him
oh no what we got going on over here
hey we we can't afford any guys getting
suspended right now so
someone's got to keep tristan thompson
we need him
okay look at phil lynch trying to get
the angle on him like a middle
linebacker he is
they call that a spy
all right let's take a look let's see
craig craig and thompson talking a
little bit
oh nothing nothing big nothing happening
[Music]
it's all good they each get a check
let's see if they hug
after the game yeah seriously
i doubt it finally i know no hugs today
no hugs for you tristan's my guy just
because that bridges will take and
miss a three